umgekehrt kommt jetzt willkommen alter
halt dass hier weniger herzlich
willkommen was geht auf willkommen beim
neuen video und es heißt mega oder ich
habe mir gedacht ich lebe heute das info
einfach mal im aufzug auf und zwar ist
der letzte part von zehn styles von
schülern echt hammer gut angekommen das
habe ich natürlich mehr gefreut willst
du so dass man sobald sie das video ist
echt richtig gut angekommen
deswegen habe ich mir gekommen drese
einfach mal zweite part dieses mal wir
müssen uns ein bisschen beeilen die
haben jetzt 07 styles geschafft ist halt
scheiße aber deswegen gibts halt des ice
von pärchen mittlerweile meine freundin
ich wünsche euch ganz viel spaß wenn ihr
bock kommt auf den weiteren partnern
wieder zehn styles von irgendwas lassen
da ich bin sagt weil
20.000 vcs machen war das oder ich
alleine mit keine ahnung geben und ich
würde sagen wir fangen an der aufzug
geht zu und jetzt war wieder runter ich
mache die mannequins
der winter nicht sagen wir von viel spaß
und let's go mit typ number one
[Musik]
guten abend münchen guck mal ich hab dir
zu unserem 23 tägigen jubiläum einen
kleinen strauß blumen besorgt gewesen
die romantischen vom schlafen und so
zähneputzen oder komm lass mich mal
anfangen heute
[Musik]
kommt auf bisschen dreckig zu machen
mallorca mit benutzern die haare machen
stehen die äußerst gut
die ekligen entrust herzlich willkommen
bei einem neuen genau elf zwei raten
leute heute sind wir zusammen hier in
köln wir verbringen den super
entspannung tollen tag zusammen und wir
haben uns gedacht wir nehmen euch gleich
mal mit und damit ich es auch gar nicht
von der samantha schaut auch auf jeden
fall wie eben kanal vorbei das beauty
palace ja und wir gehen jetzt erst mal
was die leute im moment macht macht doch
mal bitte da genau hier neben der
pflanze macht doch mal bitte ein schönes
bild für instagram
ich markiere ich natürlich auch doch
schnell ein kuss für das video die
youtuber diesmal kannst du das auch echt
mal selber holen für mich ich hol dir
immer alles was du mir sagst du holst
wasser ich will aber auch man das
erstmal alleine max und ich musste alles
für dich machen
ich bin es langsam echtzeit wie schon
gesagt du kannst ja auch mal selber was
holen
du willst du jetzt auf der stelle mein
okay ich mache ja schon die frau erst
mal ein glas 70% neutralität stilles
wasser von originaler vulkan quelle aus
großbritannien bestellt videos immer
möchte tschuldigung nochmal die nur die
frau die hosen an abwärme von mir wir
halt die fresse kämen
alles muss man dir selber machen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
punkt 10 uhr schlafenszeit morgen steht
die arbeit an kriegen kurs und großer
rauch schon kein gekriegt
die deutschen
ich bin ja schon wieder verdammt horn
lasst uns doch jemand in die ecke legen
kommen nein sie hat doch keiner wir
waren noch geradezu vertrau mir doch mal
hier sind da und dann setzt er sieht uns
keiner nein
wie noah heute
ich würde sagen ich hoffe es hat euch
gefallen ich schon sagt mit 20.000 chips
partner baa3 mit zehn starts wieder von
irgendwas anderem das war für den
videochat mal die 6
und wir sehen uns morgen oder gekommen
und haut rein
[Musik]
was ist da drin gewesen
guck mal